الاضراب ريما مستمر من طرف ضباط الهجره
وحراس الحدود 4 ايام سينتهي هذا الاضراب
صباح الثلاثاء المقبل ولكن هناك جوله
ثانيه من من الاضرابات تمتد لاربعه ايام
اخرى ربما ستكون الاسوء بحسب بعض
التحميلات ولكن المطالب مطالب هؤلاء همم
المدربين عن العمل
جدا خارج العبيد من المسافرين وهمم ومن
يريدون المجيء الى هذا البلد يختارون هذه
الفتره همم من السنه ولكن يبدو ان هؤلاء
المسافرين استمعوا واخذوا بنصيحه
المسؤولين سواء من قبل هذه المطارات السته
التي اعلن فيها هذه الاضرابات وهي مطارات
وهيسترو بالاضافه الى
جنوب البلاد لكن الحكومه مصره على انها
ستق فقط طيب رفع اجور بالنسبه لا تتعدى ال
5% وهناك ربما امكانيه ان تمتد هذه
الاضرابات لتشمل
مطارات ومواني اكثر مما سيشل البلاد اكثر
مما هي عليه الان مصطفى بكره بوكسنج داي
وبلشت التنزيلات والسيلز يعني بيتروا كثير
هذا اليوم ل- اا تجار همم والمحطه محطه
القطار من خلفك شبه مقفله ماذا نتوقع غدا
ااااه القطار عمال سكك الحديديه سيستمرون
في اضرابهم حتى صباح الثلاثاء المقبل
وهناك ايضا خمسه ايام اخرى ابتداء من
الثالث من يناير الى غايه السابع من هذه
الاضرابات حتى هذه اللحظه في هذه الفتره
الحساسه جدا ستكلف الاقتصاد البريطاني
مليار و500 مليون اذا ما اخذنا بها
الاعتبار المصاريف هؤلاء الذين يريدون ان
ان نستمتعوا بهذه الفتره المقاهي في
المطاعم يعني قطاع الضيافه هو اكبر
المتضررين بالاضافه الى قطاع السكك الحديد
وبالتالي همم يعني همم المشاكل ربا ستزيد
ولكن هذه المصاريف التي يمكن ان تصرف في
المتاجر ربما لن يتم صرفها وبالطبع ال-
يعني المصروفات والانفاق العام يعني كما
لاحظنا بانه هو اقل بكثير مما يعني ان
ربما دخل هذه سيكون اقل بكثير من السنه
الماضيه
في راس السنه الى بريطانيا كيف تنقل اذا
مش عبر القطارات هل في زحمه بالطرقات بسبب
التعطيل
همم هناك الحافلات وهناك ايضا بعض
القطارات المحدوده التي تربط بعض نواحي
المنطقه التي يتواجد فيها الشخص وبالتالي
هناك يمكن اعتماد على همم استخدام السياره
او حتى سيارته اجره ولكن بشكل عام ربما
ستكون هذه الفتره هي اهدى فتره سنشهدها
منذ سنوات يعني قليله الماضيه